next up the new york post has some
interesting results from
a new survey they found that among women
who admitted to cheating the most
popular pet that they had i don't know
why they did this study but it was a cat
so if you own a kitty you're more likely
to go on the prowl is what they're
saying
and also if you have a fish you might be
a little slippery because fish came in
second oh wow so all these women with
cats are fee lion to their partners wow
wow ross do you think there's anything
there
i think
i just thought that pun was so intricate
it was a multi-syllabic pun which went
on the powell oh yeah it was on the
brown trophy lions if he allowed the
feline
the cat it makes sense to me because
it's like first of all cats
i don't know they're a little bit of a
sociopathic animal
and like like i love like we have two
cats i'm so in love
[Laughter]
i dated a guy named mr mustache
but he didn't realize that was his name
no no no no no
no but no but cats have this thing where
um
like like i was where i was trying to
write a will have you ever written a
word i have and i need to update it a
terrifying thing because some of the
people i left stuff to i got to change
that
i just thought they didn't mind yeah
yeah they were very well and it was like
pets and i was like pets like
you know we got our cats at a shelter
that would be a real rags to riches
story
they get they they pocket that kind of
cash after judging me for all these
years but my my experience with cats is
like they really do judge you especially
when you're taking a shower they're like
oh yeah you're going to use that much
water really really yeah you can do that
or you can do this
done
done and so eco-friendly oh no just lick
yourself no water no water
[Music]